déjà condamné deux fois pour les
meurtres de deux enfants patrick vi qui
continue de clamer son innocence va
connaître son troisième procès fait
nouveau le journal l'a vu lui qu'un haut
rhin publie aujourd'hui des éléments en
tendant à prouver que le tueur en série
francis heaulme se trouvait sur les
lieux du crime qui sont reprochés à
patrick dils la principale information
est temps que francis heaulme aurait
avoué aux gendarmes s'est rapproché des
cadavres et vue l'assassin qui ne serait
pas patrie glisse christophe nella
jean-pierre pasta six mois de travail
120 témoins auditionnés d analyse
criminelle c'est une véritable contre
enquête qu'on menait les gendarmes de la
section de recherches de metz un rapport
qui fait état de nouveaux doutes quant à
la culpabilité de patrick dils la
présence de ce dernier au moment des
faits n'est toujours pas avérée il est
en revanche se resserre sur francis
heaulme le tueur en série souligne le
rapport a été aperçu sur les lieux du
crime par trois personnes dont deux
pêcheurs il atteste que francis heaulme
était non seulement à proximité des
lieux du crime mais sur la voie de
chemin de fer le jour où ils le
rencontrent que deuxièmement il portait
des marques de champ suffisamment
importante pour que
quinze ans plus tard le témoignage des
prêts des pêcheurs soient très précises
sur ce point
les éléments de ce rapport les avocats
des parties en présence les connaissent
depuis plusieurs mois la différence
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
gendarmes eux-mêmes qui font état de
leurs doutes chez les deals c'est le
soulagement eux qui n'ont jamais douté
de l'innocence de leurs enfants
reprennent espoir
que ce rapport ne donne beaucoup
d'espoir et beaucoup de choses qu'on
savait qu'on a qu'a été des terrains
mais hélas la justice n'a pas tenu
compte et maintenance et redit encore
une fois donc je pense que ça sera bon
pour lyon
lyon où sera rejugé patrick dills en un
mois maintenant les jurés de ce procès
vont forcément avoir connaissance de ce
rapport reste à savoir s'il va les
influencer